the first is every Weston's worst
nightmare 30 hungry customers who will
arrive an order all at once
first stop the milestone in Sheffield
I'm actually standing on what used to be
called pimps corner in the old red-light
district now this is amazing location
for a fantastic restaurant
it's run by four local lads
front-of-house are the owners mark and
Matt who sunk every penny into this
business
the kitchen is headed by young guns
Simon and James cage fighter no one
[ __ ] with you or service do they only
of them these guys are real they craft
us you can see that just from the minute
we shake their hands it's solid like a
plate of Sheffield steel I love the fact
that they've made their name by breaking
all the rules serving up hearty organic
dishes like roll pig's head and Trotter
sausages and what's that there are pigs
we have fun right
bring your own pigs and yes many yeah we
encourage customers to actually go out
there and get their hands dirty and
start foraging for us well swap it for
you know a meal allotment and she's
become old buy a house for you guys in
just three years the milestone of storm
Sheffield's restaurant scene and the
locals love it
it's amazing
I'll go for the nurse Rafi nice made on
the nettle yaki there's a lot of metal
in there in there yeah the nikes
delicious really good indeed I think
what I like more than anything is
feathers very seasonal very nice I
thought that food was easily of a
mission star standard today you've got a
chance to become the best of British
show-off
I mean really sure off people used to do
because of move and they did used to
think of a cocky little [ __ ] but I'm
passionate I'm dedicated and I've got
the drive to take it further
good because my diners are expecting
something incredible and they all need
to be served two courses in just two
hours